is different for men and for women
so like a man cheating is like him
buying another girl house
where a woman cheating it's her it's her
sleeping with someone else yes sorry I
understand that men are biologically
different men I mean they're they're
wired to kind of sow their seed I
understand that it's not in their nature
to be monogamous but that doesn't mean
it's beneficial for them and their
family in society as a whole no I agree
with you I don't I don't condone
cheating but I just think it's like if
you find a one percent guy like it's
like okay I don't feel bad for NBA wives
like I cheated on what'd you think
yeah like you know what I mean so I
think the point is like if a guy has
like all of the things that women want
it's not likely that he's going to be
faithful and a lot like and I think
because I kind of come from a Christian
like background too and I don't condone
it but it's like that's kind of how like
those groups run I know that because
they just happen like women shouldn't
like if loyalty truly matters to you you
shouldn't like date stuff like you
shouldn't date or marry somebody that's
going to cheat on you if that matters to
you but I don't think that saying oh I
have options I I should be allowed to
exercise my options is is necessarily
healthy see yeah well I say yes though
men need to maintain discipline in order
to safeguard against relationships more
than their relationships however there's
a fundamental difference depending on at
what stage you meet that man in his life
if you allowed a man to grow if you see
the ambition work with him help him
develop as a man and he attains that one
percent status by all means he should
give you his sexual exclusivity but if
you buy into his lifestyle your meeting
when it's already made then you don't
deserve that then the reason being is
because men have to create their value
while swimming are born of value so sex
means something completely different to
us so I think whilst I say many to
maintain discipline it's their choice
because
Amanda even have a seat at the sexual
Marketplace has to become something so
if you didn't help him become that thing
you can't demand that he be sexually
exclusive to you
well okay so I get I get what you said
but I think
so
yeah so if you if you work your way up
to the one person I do feel as though
like yes you may have options and you
can kind of sow your seed but if a woman
is in the one percent as well and you're
dating her but like from what male
standards right not necessarily
financially but physically emotionally
maturity intellectually
would you have a problem would you would
you have a problem with a woman having a
sugar daddy if the Sugar Daddy had a
vasectomy and you're not worried about
paternity tests
because because that would mean that
she's not like she's not content with
you providing and if you're married to a
woman and she's still having sex with
you but you're not satisfied with that
are we then it's on the condition that
I'm also one percent individual yes then
then of course not why would I waste my
time I could literally have almost any
woman that I want so why would yeah but
but it's it's not easy to replace a one
percent woman just like it's not easy to
replace it it kind of is though for
those guys it's not that hard the new
girl turns 22 every day we're like we're
like women like when are you ever gonna
be in contact with the one percent guy
yeah but it's a real occasion but
realistically though like yeah they're a
young fertile beautiful and some
virginal women but like do you want like
a lot of drama that comes out I'll say
this ideally in the sonority and you
said if you do find a one percent woman
then irrespectful when she meets you
then she's a one percenter you should do
what you can to keep her the perspective
I come from is more the realistic aspect
where I can't determine whether you're
that one percent if I was to lose all my
earnings tomorrow would you be there for
me or are you just here for the good
times because I can't determine that
because you haven't been there from the
start you don't deserve my exclusivity
because if my money goes do you go I
would never know so that's exactly what
I was gonna get to I think a lot of
people that talk about this on the
internet talking about like oh if I'm a
one percent person I should be allowed
to cheat like a lot of these guys don't
realize because like we've we've been
living in a bull market from 2009 to
present like people don't realize like
money can go very quickly and so if I'm
dating a guy that happens to be in the
one percent and he's cheating on me
while he's making all this money if he
loses it tomorrow when he was in his
prime when he had options he was
cheating on me so what what incentive do
I have as a woman to to really stick
around well I'm saying if I'm not
married like and it's just dating
because I I've value marriage a lot but
what incentive do I have to build this
man up only for him to to sleep around
and have sex with other women and and
treat other women when I was the one
that was building that
that's what I said so if you help me
build with it then you'd absolutely you
deserve my sexual exclusivity but if
you've met me in my Prime with all my
money you've just bought into my
lifestyle that you just don't get that
but if you but if you didn't have money
realistically you're not gonna get like
the like hottest girl like what what you
would worry about me I'm not saying you
I'm talking I'm referring to a one
percent man like let's just say you met
and high school and you fell in love
like that guy on the video like
gosh I don't want to insult him I mean
more like
um you're probably not going to attract
like a Victorious Secret model so like
if you were to attain the one percent
wouldn't you kind of look at her being
like um I don't know I could probably
find a girl that's like better kind of
thing I just say look average men
they aren't afforded the luxury of
cheating so they should absolutely be
faithful I'm gonna say once you've been
once you've achieved a certain status
then the world is your oyster and that
includes women so
again if you've built with me then you
have every reason that man has to stay
loyalty because you're a part of the
reason you're successful if you had
nothing to do with him obtaining his
success then you can't demand stuff of
him like why why you when is it
like literally I could open my eyes as
women everywhere it doesn't make any
sense logically especially if I want to
fulfill my biological imperative because
what you're asking to do is conform to
your standard which puts me at
disadvantage yeah but there's there's a
lot of things that I want to do that are
not healthy for me and that would have a
negative effect on society like
um well I'm not I'm not into drugs or
anything but like for me I love sugar so
if I like consumed sugar constantly and
I was spending all my money at bakeries
and I was and and I had a and then I
ended up getting a diabetic problem and
I ended up getting heavy like that would
that would be a problem for my health
that would be like a burden on society
in many ways that doesn't mean just
because you want to do it doesn't mean
it's good Society was built on polygamy
actually like every all every King
throughout all of history has had
multiple women so to say it's not
healthy for society when that's how
Society this bill is just incorrect but
if you love this woman if you genuinely
love her imagine you want to put her
through such insecurities such Agony why
would you want your sons to look up to
because men men love men love in
different ways yes I understand that if
you're getting the key thing I'm what
I'm really saying is find your man young
and stay with him that's really what I'm
saying but your women are out here
sitting on the sidelines Waiting for God
to blow up and then say look oh hey here
here I am you haven't done nothing to
deserve that so why do you deserve that
lifestyle when I've had to work day and
night killing myself most successful men
are like you don't understand what they
have to go through to attain that level
of status but then to say well I've just
come out of nowhere and now you have to
give me all of that you have plus give
me your exclusivity it makes zero sense
because you haven't had to do that you
haven't had to struggle to reach that
status if you had done it with him you
deserve everything he has to offer and
more but if he didn't do that with him
there's no reason why he deserved that
yeah and I and I understand but men and
women are different women are kind of
born like a 10 or they're born in eight
they're born a four men do have to build
themselves and that's just the common
understanding that that you have is and
then if you're a tan and you're
submissive and you have some sort of
skill and you're loyal and you're nice
and you're not argumentative like like
men like historically speaking have
worked have built like have put
everything into their business into
their career so that they could attain a
woman like that so then to say that
she's not entitled to anything I mean no
one's entitled to anything but I think I
think the point is they're never going
to have the same amount of Leverage as a
one percent guy because a new girl turns
I mean 22 throughout history 18 whatever
it is every day so you're just you're
never gonna have the same amount of
Leverage as a one percent guy I'm not
saying it's right I'm not I'm not
putting my moral judgment like my dad's
a top one percent guy he didn't cheat on
my mom but like the point is those guys
have to leverage and if they want to do
it they can and a lot of girls are okay
with it yeah they can do it but I think
you should certainly be clear about it
before you enter I congratulations I
agree most even in the red pill most
coaches will say be honest
yeah I mean it might it may be difficult
to find a woman that would be willing to
you think oh no a lot of women a lot of
women I have I have another thing
because I know a lot
of guys they're very much in fear of
marriage which I understand because the
divorce courts are very much in their
favor but like how could you honestly
say like that they they can cheat
and then like if I married to a guy and
he cheats I if I have kids I I don't
know if I would leave for sure but if he
cheated and got some girl pregnant like
that's grounds for divorce for me and
like if you cheat and you're you're
you're at one percent guy like she can
take you for all of your money so like
I just feel like it's kind of Leading
Men astray in some ways no I agree with
you I think it's a high risk I don't I
don't morally agree with it but I'm not
trying to change like what the what is
the world yeah and like when you're in
certain circles that's just how it is
like wipes will shake side chicks hands
yeah no just become Sister Wives yeah I
also feel like there are sacrifices that
are made on both parties typically when
a man when a man enters a committed
relationship he promises that he won't
have sex with other women and a woman
promises that she won't leave him when a
man with better resources or is better
looking or whatever it is comes along
right but he's talking about the girls
that wait at the finish line
so he's talking about the girls that
just want a guy that has everything like
it's like you're selling a Disney fairy
tale when you want a guy that has all of
the things you look for and he's going
to give you monogamy well like he's a
top one percent earner I think that's
dicey though because like from my
perspective I'm 20. but I know exactly
what I want I want to live in the
mountains I want to have a strong loving
masculine man that shares my values I've
already said this where I can live in
the mountains homeschool my kids and we
just kind of escape from modern society
but like I I happen to date guys that
are typically like late 20s early 30s
because they know what they want they
have their life together I'm not here
like being someone's babysitter a lot of
the 25 year old guys that I know that I
happen to be friends with are still
gaming playing like you know they act
like children and I don't think it's
necessarily wrong for a woman to want
somebody that that has their life
together but do you demand a guy that
makes like 120 thousand pounds a year no
I mean if he happens to have it that's
great but it's not like right that's
what I'm saying you're not you're not
coming in with unrealistic standards you
just want to homeschool your kids and
live in the mountains and I think what
Eddie's talking about more is women that
wait at the finish line and are after
superficial things well if they're after
superficial things you know not to wife
her oh maybe so look at Jeff Bezos
oh wait yeah okay sorry I thought you
were talking about Mackenzie it's the I
don't know who Mackenzie is MacKenzie's
the one that was with him when he
started the business no no I'm talking
about the new one okay like the the one
that was like hitting on Leo in front of
him oh my goodness
yeah but I mean if you're a one percent
guy you should know if you if you know
like anything about divorce courts and
that like maybe try not to go for girls
like that but it's hard I think it's
hard I think it's hard for men
like I said I always preach I need to
maintain discipline and you should
properly sift through women before you
pick the one but
when the woman comes with an agenda
they're powerful attaining their goal
so because the the women will Target
footballers and they find a way to do it
I don't know how where they find a way
to do it and it happens so I got like I
can't speak for it but if a woman wants
a guy she's attractive enough she'll
find a way to get into a circle
yes that's true but I still feel like
I I get what you're saying and I
understand it but I do think that it
should definitely be clear if cheating
is on the table I agree most people will
say that like a lot of and um those
circles a lot of people have just like
an arrangement
where they they kind of know what it is
yeah
yes that's not my thing like I wouldn't
do that but I think it's interesting
that we're spending so much time talking
about one percent of the population
when not that doesn't really apply to
most of us
um I think there are a lot of people who
would like to be a member of the one
percent
um and you know good for them but behave
like it when you are part of the one
percent not just because you have
Ambitions to be part of the one percent
and sure as hell don't cheat on your
missus
it is disloyal as
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible